kind of just i just think it's all about  the examples that you have of a marriage  because  whenever i hear young people talk about  marriage it always sounds so  down you know i can't have enough fun  you know i can't you know go give up  everything and sometime in the future  kind of like oh yeah i will one day and  there's nothing wrong with being  submissive everybody all the women see  submissive a bad thing it's not a good  thing if you've got a man leading you  you know a marriage for a woman is great  she's got nothing to lose she can go in  with nothing and she can come up with  everything so as far as i'm concerned is  this like  if you've got a good example of marriage  then you will see marriage is a good  thing  and all around